[Music]
chadwick boseman's death came as a shock
to many and left fans all over the world
at a complete loss
he'd become a household name following
his run as t'challa and marvel studios
black panther and took part in the
biggest movie of all time
avengers end game give it to me
bozeman bravely fought a four-year-long
battle with colon cancer which he kept a
total secret from the public and
appeared as strong as ever
now that the once in a lifetime talent
is gone fans are wondering how much more
of bozeman's work will be released for
his biggest star as he was
bozeman didn't have a lot of future
projects in the works but what many
don't realize is that the 43 year old
actor had much bigger aspirations in the
entertainment industry in fact he had
plans for at least one non-acting
project in particular that was announced
recently and was beginning to take shape
a mere 10 days before his unexpected
passing the news broke that bozeman was
putting together a project with family
guy and american dad creator seth
macfarlane titled little rock 9. the
limited series is set in 1957 in little
rock arkansas
focusing on nine black students as they
worked to situate themselves in a
previously all-white central high school
in the wake of the 1954 brown versus
board of education supreme court ruling
which declared segregation
unconstitutional in the united states
the show derives its story from the
real-life historical figures in the
little rock nine and from the memoir
a mighty long way my journey to justice
at little rock central high
the author colada walls lanier was the
youngest of the group and made history
as the first black woman to graduate
from the school making her life and
experiences during the civil rights
movement the central thrust of the
program
when i walked across that stage when
they called my name and gave me that
diploma
[Music]
that was it for me in an august 2009
interview with npr
walls lanier opened up about what
motivated her to write her memoir
after attending a 30th anniversary event
for the little rock 9 at central high
and after speaking with bill clinton who
was the governor of arkansas at the time
wall's lanier felt writing about her
experience would be beneficial she said
i thought that maybe i should do this
and see how it works with talking to
young people that at the age that i was
at that time
and that started me talking to high
school students and from there it took a
long time though i must admit to get to
this point of writing my memoir because
i had pushed so much into the recesses
of my mind and it had to be pulled out
and it was painful
alongside mcfarland bozeman signed on to
executive produce the series but his
untimely death has undoubtedly and
understandably brought little rock
nine's production to a halt for the time
being
after news of bozeman's untimely death
broke mcfarland joined the countless
celebrities who have taken to twitter to
remember the talented actor who was so
much more than just a movie and tv star
he was a kind-hearted person and a great
man and that's something everyone
macfarlane included recognized he wrote
deeply saddened over the passing of
chadwick boseman a great talent and a
kind man gone far
too soon my thoughts are with his family
and friends during this difficult time